freyr is a god of harvest Agriculture
and fertility often invoked in context
where those themes are relevant like in
springtime for instance his association
with fertility can be seen from his
depiction often including an erected
penis freyja likewise is one of the most
interesting of the Gods she might have
very old origins in the religious
traditions of Scandinavia maybe even
older than the other Indo-European
deities
like her brother she's a goddess of
fertility a goddess of sex love and
eroticism but she's also more versatile
than that similar to Odin she's the
goddess of seder a kind of mystical
practice that was usually performed and
associated with women in particular
she's also a goddess of death and rules
over one kind of afterlife that we
mentioned earlier the famous
mythological stories frequently involve
freyja thus perhaps the most Central and
popular of the goddesses in Norse
mythology